drame parce qu'ils étaient excédés par
la présence d'immigrés un jeune homme
tout juste majeur a tué un tunisien de
30 ans le crime raciste s'est passé à
nice mercredi
de plus s'est déroulée en deux temps la
première fois simple pistolet d'alarmé
puis l'agresseur va chercher un 22 long
rifle et revient pour tuer le jeune
tunisien est en état de mort clinique
pascal richard une petite route de la
périphérie ouest de nice c'est ici que
ce tunisien de 30 ans a été abattu
derrière ce crime un niçois de 18 ans
excédé par la présence des immigrés
mercredi matin la victime sortait de ce
foyer sonacotra le moment choisi par
jean baptiste figo et ses deux complices
pour lui tirer plusieurs coups de
pistolet d'alarmé
après avoir raccompagné ses amis djigo a
même pris le temps de revenir achevé sa
victime resté inanimé sur le bord de la
route
deux balles de 22 long rifle dans la
tête ce soir une délégation de sos
racisme s'est rendu à matignon pour
exprimer sa colère et son émotion et que
cette violence raciste deviennent
général et est banal ces immigrés est
paraît-il était en est en situation
régulière
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a le droit de
tirer sur les gens parce que leurs
papiers sont de telle ou telle couleur
qu'est ce que l'on sait la situation
est-ce qu'on va commencer par calomnier
la victime comme c'est le cas trop
souvent dans ce genre d'affaires cela
pour nous est intolérable ce que nous
constatons c'est que en 1989
en france on peut encore mourir d'être
simplement un immigré opérait au cndd
berdja mort lutte ce soir contre la mort
djigo lui est écroué depuis hier soir
ses deux complices laissé en liberté
la brouille de près de 30 ans des deux
géants communiste chinois soviétique est
sur le point le point de prendre fin
lundi gorba tout